all right welcome back to CBS this
morning I'm Anthony Mason with Gayle
King and Tony Tecopa we're learning
dramatic new details about one of the
most high-profile investigations in the
country on 60 minutes last night
correspondent Sharon alphonse he took us
inside the jail cell where convicted sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein was found dead
in August after a five-month
investigation 60-minutes obtained photos
of the autopsy and the jail cell some of
them we caution you are quite disturbing
Sharon spoke to a forensic pathologist
dr. Michael Baden who was hired by Mark
Epstein to investigate his brother's
death
it appears he had some kind of sleep
apnea machine you can see a long
electrical cord yes there were other
wires and cords present that it would
have been easy to use to hang oneself
within a few minutes but the key reason
dr. Baden thinks Jeffrey Epstein's death
might be a homicide is because of the
unusual fractures he saw in Epstein's
neck
there were fractures of the left the
right thyroid cartilage and the left
highlight bone this is an autopsy photo
of Epstein's broken hyoid bone a
u-shaped bone that sits under the jaw
the part of the tongue attaches to the
thyroid cartilage sits at the front of
the neck I have never seen three
fractures like this in a suicidal
hanging and dr. Michael Baden joins us
good morning dr. Baden thanks for being
here morning you observed the entire
four-hour autopsy of Jeffrey Epps I did
what stood out to you the most in that
what stood out to me the most was that
the ligature mark was made after a few
hours he'd been dead for a few hours at
the time he was discovered and that
there were multiple fractures of the
Adam's apple the thyroid cartilage and
the thyroid and the hired bone that are
more indicative of a homicidal
strangulation than a suicidal
strangulation so in a thousand cases
that you've reviewed in the
New York state prison system since
Attica right you've never seen a three
bone fracture in a suicide in a suit
that's correct but the New York State
Medical Examiner which also looked at
this they say no we have seen it and we
think it's a suicide so I've been
reviewing all the records since Attica
as to when the suicide occurs we haven't
in New York State's Prison seen that
kind of fractures number one number two
maybe our our experiences are different
but this certainly suggests that it
could be a homicide but it's important
though to point out to that could be
good 60 minutes also to Tony's opponent
also talked to other pathologists who
also agree with the suicide findings
you're being paid by the Epstein family
isn't it in your best interest to go
along with what they believe have that
happen they want to know what happened I
think that Mister the the brother or the
estate would just as soon have this to
be a suicide because there's no
advantage to them to be a homicide mark
Epstein is now concerned about a
homicide if his brother was killed
because he knew too much
is he also at jeopardy other people at
jeopardy so they don't think that their
brother was murdered well because the
autopsy found things they feel the
brother may have been murdered but as a
medical examiner when I was chief
medical examiner in New York City just
because I would find the jail suicide
doesn't mean that I was on the side of
the city or the state we have to call it
the way we see it so it doesn't matter
what I'm being paid by New York City or
being paid by the family I want to go
back to the point you made we don't know
the position of Epstein's body when he
was found dead that's correct and that's
a crucial question it's a very big
question because the marks on the neck
is not at all typical for a hanging
suicide a hanging suicide 90% of the
time there are no fractures maybe 10%
15% they could be a hyoid or a thyroid
fragment you don't have three fractures
with with the weight of the body on the
ligature you have to have
a lot more pressure by ligature by hands
to get those fractures you also say that
that the that the wounds on Epstein's
neck and we have pictures of those with
as we caution you these are these are
disturbing pictures do not match the
noose that was found in his cell that's
right there are a number of things on
the news the the noose is a very narrow
noose and there's a little imprint on
one of the nooses of a pressure of a
mark that could not have come from the
smooth cheese that's attached a part of
the news that then it's on the neck
adjacent on the skin that looks more
like an imprint from a rope rather than
from a smooth bedsheet and there's
nothing on the bedsheet that blood or
that would indicate it was around his
neck and there the FBI or the medical
examiner would have done swabs for DNA
on the ligature whose DNA is on it was
an Epstein alone or was it have seen
somebody else and so important because
we're talking about justice for his
alleged victims and all that's right the
question of did he have other stories
yeah but there's no advantage to the
family that this is a homicide or
suicide there's no no money involved no
all right that's right dr. Michael Baden
thank you very much for being with us
thank you
you